they laughing here cuz bite one guy to
come all down with his bare hands he's
still in there turn around mr. you see
your hands slowly aggravated assault is
a felony in this state mr. Reacher
process him and get him to County tier
things are gonna happen in the next 90
seconds excuse me first that phone over
there's gonna ring second you're gonna
be wearing these cuffs on your way to
prison that is one magnificent prophecy
mr. Reacher
she's gonna keep on ringing thanks for
tipping us off to that Sheriff when are
you coming to DC I move around a lot
you're a legend folks wonder why you
left Purple Heart Silver Star there's
this big dent in the dusk people say you
made it with someone's cutter Jack
creature from agent Turner major Turner
has been arrested on what charge
espionage he's been sent him how much
does region know how's it going I want
being followed you think you're
invulnerable that's right maybe I rip
your arm off beat you to death with it
I'm sorry about this
each he's here to kill you
my men were shot by one of our own this
is bigger than I imagined you ever lose
anyone on your watch Reacher
your internet
you think you above the law
but I'm not the law
start running cuz I'm gonna start
hunting and when I find you I'm gonna
kill you all
it's a haircut all you guys go to the
same barber
you